hi there and welcome to the last part of
on the measure of intelligence by
Francois Shola
this last part concerns the arc
challenge that Chalet has proposed or
the arc dataset which stands for the
abstraction and reasoning corpus and
we're just quickly going over the data
set look how it's built and discuss what
kind of solutions might be relevant
right here so if you haven't seen the
last videos in this series this is the
last one of a series you might not
exactly know what's going on but I think
you can you can keep up pretty well
because this part is fairly independent
of the other parts and it's just cool to
think about even if you haven't seen the
other ones I encourage you to go see the
other ones but it's not necessary ok
let's jump in so the arc is a challenge
currently running a cackle challenge but
in essence it is a data set and let me
just jump into one of the tasks of the
data set so in this data set you always
have the task in the following form so
you always have multiple input examples
like this or say these are called the
the training examples and then you have
a test example in this case you have
three training example of one test
examples so an entire if you think of
this in a machine learning way this
entire thing here is your X and this
thing here is your Y ok so the label is
going to be the output of the last
example that you you don't know that now
in Indi of course in the training data
set you do but in the test you don't so
each one of these as I said is is
demonstrated these are the demonstration
examples and then you're supposed to
sort of learn the regularity out of the
demonstration examples and then on this
test example you are supposed to apply
this regularity that you learned so in
here a human can fairly
accurately see that there are these
black squares in each image and that in
the training samples the output will
always sort of exactly match into the
place of these black squares as you can
see this is like a high rectangle it
goes here it has the same amount of
tiles and so on and you can also see
that whatever colors are in here sort of
are the continuation of a symmetric
pattern so here this is exactly the same
as up here but you know flipped or
turned by 180 degrees so there is a
notion of symmetry right here so
technically one could compute this one
would say oh that's probably going to be
the three rows and this bunch of things
and it's probably going to be the same
as this one down here but just flipped
on its head so as a human you you get
this even without a description you you
realize like oh this is like a a regular
pattern it's symmetric there's a hole in
it and apparently the thing here always
fills the hole I can see that you know
three examples are enough for me to
confirm that that's what's going on and
I see the hole here so I'm going to do
the same thing so you can already see
how these things are constructed in
every this is not the only task by the
way this is just one task okay there are
1,000 tasks in this data set of this
sort of nature now they're not always
three demonstration examples I believe
there can be more or less but what's
always the case is they always each of
these training examples consists of
these demonstration examples and this
test example each of the demonstration
examples consists of an input grid and
an output grid the input grid and output
grid they can be anywhere from one by
one to 30 by 30 okay
anywhere in between that and the colors
here I believe there are nine different
colors that can go that are just encoded
by nine different numbers but there are
nine different colors that these things
can have you can see black blue
orange red dark blue and so on and the
output grid exactly the same now in this
test example you can only see the input
grid you cannot see the output grid and
that means you don't even know how large
it should be you can see right here
they're not all the same size the output
grids in fact not even the input grids
have to be always the same size but you
have to now come up with an output grid
you have to first decide how big it is
and we've here we've determined since
the hole has three rows we're probably
gonna make three rows and it has like
seven columns we're probably gonna make
seven columns and that's the sort of
thing you have to do and then not only
do you have to decide how big it is you
now have to decide in each cell what
color you put in and only if this thing
exactly matches the terrain or the test
label you get a you get a point
otherwise you get no point okay so in
the training tasks there are I believe
four hundred of these tasks and then
there are four hundred more as test
split but these are still public and
then there are two hundred that are
secret there are I guess part of this
Kaggle challenge yes the training set
features four hundred tasks while the
evaluation set features six hundred
tasks the evaluation set if is further
split into a public evaluation set of
four hundred tasks and a private
evaluation set of two hundred tasks all
tasks are unique and the set of tasks
and the set of training tasks are
disjoint sorry of test tasks and
training tests the task data is
available at this as you can see right
here so I really hope that surely will
keep these two hundred tasks as a secret
even after the cattle challenge because
it's going to be fun for people that
might want to get into this later so
here are the goals of this data set they
want to stay close to these psychometric
intelligence tests they say in predict
should be solvable by humans without any
specific practice or training and
probably also without any language
instructions so you just be able to set
a human in front of it and if the human
should be able to solve it or a large
portion of humans should be able to
solve it right ideally this test would
also differentiate humans from each
other but at this point we want to
simply assess machines so they say focus
on on measuring developer aware
generalization rather than task specific
skill by only featuring novel tasks in
the evaluation set and the novel tasks
are unknown to the developer of a test
taker so if I develop a system I'm I
don't know what what are these 200 tasks
that surely it keeps hidden I simply
submit my code and I'll figure out if my
code does well on them so they say they
want to feature a highly abstract task
must be understood by a test taker using
very few examples that's what you saw
you don't have a big training example to
learn that this task is about symmetry
and whole filling you only have 3 and
from 3 you need to recognize what's
going on and produce the output of the
test sample right quality of control for
experience by only providing a fixed
amount of training data for each task
that's what we saw and only featuring
tasks that do not lend themselves well
to artificially generating new data so
it's it's not like image net where you
can go on the internet and find a whole
bunch of images or you know some NLP
tasks where people pre train on all of
Wikipedia and all of the books in the
world because they want to understand
language better these tasks are supposed
to be such that it's it's it makes no
sense for you to go out and try to find
more data or find similar data or pre
train your model on something and then
lastly and this refers to the last few
chapters we looked at explicitly
describe the complete set of priors that
it assumes and enable a fair general
intelligence comparison between human
and machines by only requiring priors to
those innate human
close to innate human prior knowledge so
that means that whatever human have
whatever humans have as a prior built
into them by let's say evolution or that
most humans have picked up through life
those are the things that you have to
explicitly point out so and you require
that and you have to point them out
sorry
explicitly describe them such that I as
a developer of a system can build them
into my system such it's a fair
comparison
in the last chapters we looked at the
fact that a fair intelligence comparison
is only fair if two systems that are
compared to each other have the same
amount of experience and here we control
that by only providing a fixed amount of
training data and also have the same
prior knowledge and here we simply do
that by listing the human priors that
are required for the tasks that we think
that humans have and then we enable the
developers to explicitly build those
into machines so I would maybe build a
little calculator module into my a AI
that solves this tasks okay so they say
he each task consists of a small number
of demonstration examples 3.3 on average
and a small number of test examples
generally one although it might be two
or three in rare cases each example
consists of an input grade and an output
grade each grid is a literal grid of
symbols each symbol is visualized by
color there are ten unique symbols a
grid can be any height or width between
one by one and 30 by 30 so it doesn't
even need to be square right and as I
said you need to provide your own output
grid as an AI taking this test so here
are the priors that this test assumes
and we're going to look at some examples
that make it explicit acts in the
training set that where you can see
these priors in actions there is an
object Ness prior where the the task
assumes that the AI or the task tests
that the AI understand something about
objects so these are tasks that you
and only reasonably solve if you know
something about objects like you would a
human would recognize or would you know
would recognize that these things might
represent
different objects right now that's
mainly I think also due to the the black
background helps but you would even
recognize this with another background
or here the different colors indicate
that those are two different things even
though those two pixels here touch and
are different from black you would
recognize that those are two different
things because they have different color
but you would generally recognize one of
these things as an individual object if
you're not given anything here you see
for example a denoising task as a human
you can pretty quickly see what the task
is about right there appear to be these
green things they're all rectangles and
there appear to be these blue things and
on the right side there are no more blue
things but the now it's not always that
when there was a blue thing there is now
a green thing only here where it was
sort of inside a green thing is now a
green pixel whenever there was a blue
pixel outside in this black area then
there is now black so this is sort of
like the blue things were noise and
you're able to remove it this already
tests a lot of assumptions a lot of
these priors a lot of understanding of
the world so there are objects right
objects human understands that objects
are square in this case or rectangles
the human understands that it that we
need to remove the blue things going
over and the human understands that
somehow this inside relation right if
something is inside or outside of one of
these rectangles and that determines
whether we have to turn the pixel green
or black you can I mean think about how
you would train a machine to do
something like this it's not easy
especially if you don't know that this
task is coming imagine for all of these
things you don't know
that the task is coming this is just one
of 400 tasks that you know of there are
600 tasks that you don't know of that
are similar but also in a way completely
different
here's another tasks that object
influence via contact so this is your
first demonstration example a human
pretty quickly recognizes there appears
to be red thing and a blue thing and
then they appear to be together and then
in the next thing you see oh there
appears to be a blue thing in the red
thing in the next thing they appear to
be together and if you look here it
always appears to be the red thing going
to the blue thing in the most direct way
so in the in the along the grid that's
all that the human needs to see two
examples and the human most humans will
already make that inference and can now
solve if there is like if there now is a
test example where the blue thing is
like the blue thing is down here and the
red thing is here like this and it asks
you what comes next you know you know
that the red thing is going down to the
blue thing but it's very hard to train a
machine to do this so I I like this test
because it's sort of a different test
and I believe the test these tests
weren't procedurally generated these
tests were actually generated by Sholay
or you know by by actual humans that's
pretty cool and a thousand tasks like
this is going to be very hard to solve
there are even more abstract priors like
goal directed Ness
so now you here you can already see this
a little bit in that you can say well
the red thing wants to go to the blue
thing so there's a notion of time
involved maybe there's also counting and
numbers and numbers prior so here you
see like a time process so in this
demonstration example you see blue
things here red big thing and then the
next the output grid is this green
as a human immediately recognized okay
so it shoots out from the blue thing the
green thing shoots from the blue thing
hits the red wall and goes here try to
make a machine understand this this is
insane right so if you look at the more
examples it all it appears that the blue
thing always comes from somewhere like
the side of the image and the green
thing comes out obviously from whatever
is not at the at the border of the image
and then bounces of the red thing if it
hits the red thing now here you can you
can already see what's gonna happen
remember you're AI would need to first
determine aha okay
all of these output grids they seem to
be the same as the input grid so it
would need to explicitly construct the
output grid in the same manner as the
input grid because it understands this
right this is not the same in every task
then it needs to recognize the red thing
it stays in every one so it needs to put
the red thing here right from from here
and then it needs to recognize the blue
thing stays as well and then most most
shockingly it needs to recognize okay I
will draw a line in pixels and lines in
pixels are hard here and then as soon as
it would hit the red thing it bounces
off into the other direction so the from
just these three examples the machine
has to understand that and correctly
output the exact solution not an
approximate solution the exact solution
okay so yeah there are these basic
geometry and topology priors like lines
rectangular shapes symmetries rotations
translations shape upscaling
containing being contained drawing lines
connecting points and so on now let's
look at some more examples these are fun
right check out this one here so you see
green red and then somehow the green
connected to the red so this is an
example
of there has many of these priors in
many of these concepts in theirs
goal-directed ness you can already sort
of form the hypothesis that the green
wants to go to the red but also you see
that somehow it sort of appears to the
blue things seem to be maybe obstacles
and it appears to change direction when
it encounters an obstacle like here so
here you see the example and you
probably confirm so your hypothesis
could be it always goes until it hits
and then it changes direction towards
the red thing right always towards
reffing because it's not always towards
the right because he returned towards
the left so it goes somehow towards the
red thing and so it's it's pretty
ambiguous in this situation but you can
also make the assumption that it if it's
ambiguous it goes towards the middle
maybe maybe
so here again now we're actually
confirming probably so we go towards the
red thing which would be towards this
direction and we hit an object then we
go towards the red thing until we hit an
object and then we go here I'll also see
that these grids here are not the same
size so it's not always the case that
the grids of in within the same tasks
are even the same size so now here
you're again here a I would need to
recognize what size of grid it needs to
draw and what the result is so it would
need to copy this entire grid and also
change these pixels right here to be
green pixels that's hard I mean that's I
find I find this to be pretty hard this
is the line extrapolation and turning on
obstacle and efficiently reaching a goal
prior that's crazy and is there more yes
there is two more I believe yeah those
are the last examples so in this one you
can see right here there appeared to be
objects which there's this blue objects
they appear to be the same and there are
these red
and then the output grid is one of these
blue objects okay so here we again see
different objects the output grid is one
of them so as a human you can already
recognize the output grid is probably
always going to be one of these objects
and now we need to decide on which one
so we can formulate the hypothesis that
it's probably going to be the one that's
the most like here there's three of the
blue ones here there's four of the
yellow ones that's more than any other
and this year confirms our hypothesis
that the it's the object that appears
most often now I can see that there is
this notion of object Ness news you need
to upscale somehow no this is not up
scan because the grid is the same size
it's simply the image that's up scale
but you need to somehow focus be able to
focus in on one of these objects I need
to count them you need to compare the
counts via each other and now here you
can pretty easily see that output grade
is going to contain one of those blue
things as a human and here it's it's
sort of a symmetry filling test not as a
human you need one demonstration to get
this maybe you need more but many tasks
involve some sort of symmetry
okay drawing the symmetrized version
around the version of a shape around a
marker that's going to be fairly hard
for a machine to learn without without
the developer knowing that this task is
coming okay they they highlight some
differentiations to standard
psychometric tests but what I find
interesting here is that this thing what
a solution to arc may look like and what
it would imply for AI applications they
say we have found our to be fully
solvable by humans so they've set a
human in front of every every one of
these tasks and it's solvable
while many arc tasks are intellectually
challenging human test takers appear to
be able to solve the majority of tasks
on their first try without any practice
or verbal explanations in if
effect in this task you get three tries
at each at each of the at each of the
problems you get three three tries and
the humans can already solve it in one
so that just show you chose you how cool
humans are so here is a chalet suggests
a solution approach says by start by
developing a domain-specific language
capable of expressing all possible
situations all possible solution
programs for any arc task since the
exact set of work tasks is purposely not
formally definable this may be
challenging the space of tasks is
defined as anything expressible in terms
of arc pairs that would only involve
core knowledge so core knowledge is this
set of human priors that we discussed
last time like object nests and
symmetries and geometric shapes and
navigation and so on so he asks you to
basically develop a DSL that can capture
all the different tasks so so it kept
basically to find a formalism of these
tasks but it's hard because you don't
know what the tasks are gonna be so your
best bet is probably to make it formal
isn't that completely over represents
what the tasks can be right
it would require hard coding the core
knowledge priors from three point one
point two in a sufficiently abstract and
combine able program form to serve as a
basis functions for a kind of human-like
reasoning DSL
we believe that solving this specific
subproblem is critical to a to general
AI progress basically says whenever we
can describe this is like saying that
this AI progress will make a big step
once we can formally describe human
priors and while true this I feel the
hardness of this problem is as hard as
actually building general artificial
intelligence
very close to it so it is a bit of a
like how to so how to how to go how to
build a GI step one build a GI that's
sort of I mean not exactly but it's kind
of what this says right if I could
actually have this DSL to describe every
single task and I can do it you know
such that it is not not super over
capturing all the tasks then I would be
able and I would have described human
core knowledge in a sufficiently
accurate degree that I could just you
know build a GI but he goes on says
given a task use the DSL to generate a
set of candidate programs that turn the
input grits into the corresponding
output grids this step would reuse and
recombine sub programs that previously
proved useful in other arced tasks so it
says whenever you have captured the core
knowledge or whenever you have captured
the problem space in a horrible language
you can simply use that formal language
to express whatever your input is so the
that turned the input grids into the
corresponding outputs so you would put
in these demonstration examples and
describe this with your formal language
that you have and you can somehow reuse
and recombine sub programs that
previously proved useful so basically
asking you to write to come up with
source code that would generate these
demonstration examples in the language
of your DSL and then he says select top
candidates among these programs so you
would generate multiple versions of
source code that generates this these
things based on a criterion such as a
program simplicity or program likelihood
note that we do not expect that merely
selecting the simplest possible program
that works on training pairs will
generalize well to test pairs and then
use the top three candidates to generate
output grids for the test examples
so I hope the the approach here I feel
it makes sense but it is sort of over
hopeful in in my mind and that's mainly
because of of step one so step one asks
you to come up with like a programming
language that can capture all the tasks
in this all the tasks in the data set
even though you don't know what the
tasks are and that has this human core
knowledge in inside of it in a in a
formally describable way and then once
you have that programming language you
would if you're given this task where
you have you know a bunch of these
demonstration you have a bunch of these
demonstration things and then you have
the test thing you would generate all
the programs that would produce these
demonstration examples or that would
given the daemon given the input grid
would produce the output grid right you
would generate all the programs and then
you would select somehow among all these
programs the the one that you think
generalizes the most and you would use
that program to put this in and get out
the solution they say it's prob it's not
always the simplest program not always
the shortest program maybe who knows
like I feel step one is the kind of the
crucial issue here okay so they say they
make some claims here and about what
this what this would bring the community
we posit that the existence of human
level org solver would represent the
ability to program and AI from
demonstrations alone only requiring a
handful of demonstrations to specify
complex tasks to do a wide range of
human relatable tasks of a kind that
would normally require human level
human-like fluid intelligence as
supporting evidence we know that human
performance on psychometric intelligent
tests which are similar torque is
predictive of success across all human
cognitive tasks further we posit that
since the NARC sovereign human
intelligence would be
founded on the same knowledge priors the
scope of application of an arc solver
would be closer to that of human
cognition making such a solver both
practically valuable and easy to
interact with and would produce behavior
that is in line with human expectations
okay so there they're making the same
argument that anyone before has made but
they conditioned it on some things and
this is I think the conclusion of the
entire article here of on the measure of
intelligence because people have this
hope and they say that here claims are
highly speculative and Maya proved
incorrect much like Newell's 1973 hopes
that progress on chess-playing would
translate into meaningful progress in
achieving a broad range of cognitive
abilities especially if arc turns out to
feature unforeseen vulnerabilities to
unintelligent shortcuts this is the AI
effect and it basically means that
whenever you think a task as the solving
of a task represents AI and then you
actually see the solution then the
solution turns out to be not AI in the
eyes of the human so the human at first
they would say oh this task really
requires intelligence and then someone
solves the task and they'll say oh
that's not intelligence you kind of
hacked your way to that and the
expectation is that in this auric
challenge there might be a hacky way to
that but I mean the good question is
when at what is there even a task like
this auric challenge here could that is
there even the possibility of a task
where you wouldn't say that and I'm not
so sure about this they seem to be more
hopeful than I am but at least they say
the art challenge is founded on the same
priors as a human has it gives you the
same amount of experience as a human has
right and therefore it is much more
comparable to human intelligence all
right they go over some weaknesses right
here of that criticizing their own thing
generalization is not quantum
so they have a measure of generalization
in the previous chapter but they don't
use it right here test validity is not
established data set size and diversity
may be limited and so on but I've in my
mind this I would not consider this as
like an AGI task or anything like this
I'm pretty sure the solution to this
will come in a form again where people
don't really think it's it exhibits
intelligence but I do like the task as
such and as a machine learner I am very
excited to think about how machine
learning can go about solving this test
and especially with what we've seen from
something like GPT 3 that has exactly
this kind of structure where you train
on a giant dataset 12 of all you pre
train your language model but then at
inference time you input a bunch of
these demonstration examples and you ask
it for the next output so I feel that
might be a good start for for doing it
the question of course is what what then
do you pre train this model on this GPT
3/4 arc
what's the pre training data set for it
and I guess that's going to be the
challenge and it's probably going to
require people to specifically program
all of these priors into a data set
generator for pre training so that would
be my approach my approach would be
write a data set generator for
pre-training a GPT 3 model to do these
kind of tasks and in order to write the
data set generator
you'd have to basically program in all
of these priors and that's not going to
be easy because you're your best bet is
to sort of put yourself into the shoes
of chalet and be like oh if I were to
design a task what kind of things would
I do and then try to capture that that's
going to be your best bet your most
honest bet with respect to the challenge
is to try to as faithfully as possible
implement some
thing like an object ness prior where
cohesion and persistence are captured
that would be the most scientifically
sound approach to my approach all right
so that was my take on the arc dataset
if you have any comments I'm very
excited to hear comments on this if you
have already tried the orc challenge
have some insight I also welcome
comments on that and with that I'll see
you next time bye bye